i've been teaching this today really
what's the best meditation
way for me but my belt's a bit tight so
let's let's open that up for stuff
i'll tell you what is my shoulders
loosen that location
oh should i have that hand over that
one's that handle that
is my neck a bit stiff see i'm doing
everything to avoid going into a
peaceful state
is my spine stroke is my chin tucked in
you know
i could keep adding to it so i'm going
to do it
so human nature avoids one thing and
that is looking at yourself
so the one thing that most of us won't
want to do
is look at ourselves because we don't
perhaps want to see what ourself is like
and yet who is this person we're hiding
from oh
yeah who is it that we don't want to see
because we're with ourselves 24 7.
is it the person we don't know yet or is
it the person that is really deceitful
and you've been conning everybody
come on you can do it you can do it in
your head the voice saying i'll never
get it
i'm deceiving you know i wasn't
i was joking of course when i said
you're all rubbish out there well
perhaps i wasn't
so you see i mean that's the person
you've got you're facing
your face you don't want to face the
real you
so we tend to avoid everything yeah i'm
alright but i don't want to do that
there's some reason why we don't want to
do it but why don't you just watch
well i'm not even interested in watching
there's certain buttons
in us that just don't want to do things
finding out why is sometimes good
because when you
end up knowing yourself
when i wake up tomorrow morning if i'm
depressed
or i think oh i should have talked
better than that or something
i'll go but that's you isn't it
that's just you tony you know that
you've never changed in 70 years you
ain't going to change now
or but i might come on you know you're
not going to change
so you know i have a conversation with
myself and i end up going
yeah i am not okay what am i going to do
today
so i put it to one side and i get on
with the day
you see true meditation is when you go
completely blank
and you just
you don't think you don't count you
don't
talk to yourself with the voice in your
head there is absolutely nothing
one in a million people
will do that whether you're one in a
million i don't know but most of us
we like visualization or we like
guided meditation because by being here
i'm just going to talk about what i'm
pretending to think
well i can't just sit here doing nothing
can i not thinking about anything
i'd be wasting my time
why am i seeing that picture of a teddy
bear
there's all sorts of weird stuff that
gets thrown at you
if you start analyzing it'll get
involved the same as the pressure out
there where they put you under pressure
you're putting yourself under pressure
if you go
thank you for showing me the teddy bear
thank you for coming
i'm just going to open the door in my
mind now and let it go i'm going to go
back to emptiness and blank
that's the steps of trying to get to
meditation
in my about 40 years of doing it
the longest i've held is four minutes
and i went yes four minutes
because you think when you're in
meditation
it can be a long time but to be
completely blank
no voices no pitches nothing
seconds go by